au quotidien la banque alimentaire de
touraine fonctionne avec près de 70
bénévoles ces gilets orange qui lui
permettent de trier stocker et
redistribuer les denrées collectées
chauffeur caristes préparateurs de
commande ou agents d'accueil
l'association manque encore de bonne
volonté c'est un défi tous les jours que
l'on en assument d'aller chercher des
denrées dans les magasins de l'étrier de
les répartir pour les associations c'est
deux ou trois tonnes qui passe tous les
jours en produits périssables pour
assurer l'activité quotidienne il faut
environ 30 personnes par jour donc en
sachant que ba nos bénévoles sont
souvent disponibles qu'une demi-journée
ou une journée par semaine ce qui est
déjà pas mal c'est déjà un projet de
solidarité mais donc plus l'effectif est
important plus haut on peut assurer
toutes les activités et la banque
alimentaire rappelle qu'un seul bénévole
permettant moyenne la distribution de 30
mille repas voilà pour le quotidien de
l'association
mais il y a aussi une opération
ponctuelle qui demande l'engagement d'au
moins 1500 bénévoles
la collecte nationale qui se déroule
cette année les 30 novembre 1er et 2
décembre
nous serons présents dans 110 magasins
d'indre et loire
et ses bénévoles ses volontaires ils
sont à côté des caisses et récupère tout
ce que les tourangeaux veulent bien leur
donner généreusement ses divagations
d'une demi journée assez voilà il faut
il faut que ça reste un plaisir il faut
que la personne n'a envie de faire un
jeu solidaire vers les banques
alimentaires et verte ou lycées
bénéficiaires qui ont besoin de manger
correctement
l'année dernière en touraine les
collecte de la banque alimentaire ont
permis de distribuer deux millions de
repas à près de 12000 personnes en
situation de précarité